uh 6019 project and critical race theory
critical race theory more importantly is
being taught as basic curriculum
across the country if i'm if i'm not
mistaken i believe that the 1619 project
although historically inaccurate and
very stupid
uh i think that it's being taught in
maybe some select schools but it's not
like a national curriculum right
i'm pretty sure it well maybe new york
times like
maybe you can say yeah yeah and schools
are teaching it like crazy because these
teachers they they hold this idea
that's that's like crazy where where is
it happening here where is the
list well you know i followed james
lindsey for this stuff to be honest i i
don't know where the next
i actually was unaware that the 1619
project was being taught
widespread what is the gist of it
the 16 19 it's it's a historically and
accurate account of
basically america's founding and they
argue that america was founded on
um like i don't even fully understand it
either because i just know it's stupid
from education next educators around the
country are indeed teaching the 1619
project
what precisely students and other
interested observers are learning is
another question
the 1619 project is certainly
educational or at least instructive but
not the uh
not only in the ways it was intended and
they going to explain what it is
in the classroom uh random children's
books announced plans to publish four
16-19 projects
books for young readers one young adult
etc etc so yes
yeah yeah i mean so that that would
definitely be a problem but would it be
better that they learned like
a very patriotic pro america or a very
anti-america it would be better
for them to learn a the truth about
america and not have a biased truth
historically accurate account of how
america got started right
based on which which art like which uh
author which literature
i i don't know do you know well so an
example would be some might tell you
uh notably like the new york times that
america truly started in 1619. right
that's
even the author of the 16th or even one
of the people on 1619 acknowledged that
it wasn't really historically accurate
yeah it's funny because only like way
later after like they started getting
attacked relentlessly non-stop but they
want pulitzers for it so
this is this is just my problem though
is see this is
donald trump trying to combat this 1619
project by doing something that i would
argue is just as bad
i don't want a bias so so what was his
curriculum that he was going to teach
he was going to teach a pro-patriotic
which would be explicitly biased in
favor of america
that kind of a curriculum like that's
brainwashing also right
yeah we want to teach kids the truth and
listen
here's something else i promise you i
know this sounds like it's unrelated but
it is
uh one of the things i talk about a lot
on my channel is fat the fat acceptance
movement which are the the body
positivity people the people that are
really fat that claim that oh just who
cares about health let's just love your
body
i've always argued that if you love your
body you would work to change your body
and work to improve it
and i think the exact same thing goes
for the country i as a dad like i want
this country to be better i want this
country to be better for my kids
and i don't think that you can push for
genuine
and accurate change if you have a
brainwashed interpretation of america
and that you like star wars
that goes for the 1619 project as well
not really you don't you know like star
wars not really did you watch the
original
yeah what did you think that with like
luke skywalker and you know tattooing
and the death star
of course what do you think about it
yeah it's all right
who do you think uh do you like luke
skywalker in the jedi
yeah sure yeah you think like you think
what he did was cool
i haven't watched that movie in a really
long time and admittedly i have not
researched on my star wars before coming
on yeah but like you know
han solo luke skywalker you know they
were cool right they were
they were heroes yeah yeah you think
it's cool that some scraggly religious
zealots from a desert planet took a
cargo ship and blew up a military base
that's star wars yes sir and that's and
that's not like
that point is made by the left when they
say people watch star wars and don't
understand why they're cheering for it
they're cheering for a religious faction
from a desert planet taking a
cargo ship and and fighter and rebel
fighter pilots and then blowing up a
military base
it's actually clerks i think you know
with the you know was it the kevin smith
film made a really good point
they were contractors and janitors and
like regular people just working on this
base had no idea what's going on
yeah they all got killed according to
the guy in clerks they people that are
contractors have political bias and they
choose to work exactly so
you choose to work on a military base so
when al-qaeda blows it up that's your
own fault
the point is you talk about being pro
you know trump's
pro-america view of the world and it's
like sure you could argue that the
founding fathers were insurrectionist
terrorists who were just greedy slave
owners
and wanted to wanted to reject the crown
because the crown wanted its cut
and and and furthermore the british were
defending the seas for the american
colonies the
ingrates were angry over a t tax because
they didn't want to pay their fair share
well i i it's kind of ridiculous right
yeah of course and and i'm not saying
that that's the alternative to donald
trump's approach
what i'm arguing for is a just a
historically accurate
interpreter maybe that's what would have
happened of the hi of history well
that's not that's
and if that was how it was told that
wouldn't be historically accurate well
that's based on you know people's
interpretation because you could
interpret history in many different ways
but
i agree with your point that our kind of
higher learning institutions are in
our school institutions are corrupted
but i don't think it's because of trump
i think they're they've been like that
for a very long time especially since
their institution under the rockefeller
policies that wanted to make good
factory workers
and that's essentially what kind of
school is in our modern day and age
uh so there's a couple things that come
up to mind when you're talking about
this
one interesting one was the recent
decision by cornell university
that recently decided that they're going
to be making the vaccine mandatory the
covenant
covet 19 vaccine mandatory but only for
white students i was wondering
yeah is that actually a true story yes
yes cornell vaccine
and wait here's only applies to white
students and the best part is wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
hold on hold on there's one more two in
oregon they're doing grants for kova
that only go to black businesses so it's
like
yeah so when you have when you have
institutions like that that are hired by
you know the the state can i find a
little more context on that cornell i
could send you the article
if you want to we can look into it
there's also another one there's also
another incident that i would love to
get your kind of feedback on in new york
city we have the school superintendent
literally arguing and trying to make it
a mandate that if there's a poor white
kid and a middle class or rich
black kid that school resources should
predominantly go to the black kid all
right not to the poor white we got it
from the college fix
cornell vaccine mandate only applies to
white students saying
quote we recognize that due to
long-standing systemic racism and health
inequities in this country
individuals from some marginalized
communities may have concerns about
needing to agree to such requirements
for example
historically the bodies of the black
indigenous and people of uh
and people of color have been mistreated
and used by people in power sometimes
for profit or medical gain
it is understandable that the current
compact requirement may feel suspect or
even exploitative to some bypoc members
of the cornell community
additionally recent acts of violence
against black people by law enforcement
may contribute to feelings of distrust
or powerlessness
while the university strongly recommends
that non-white students comply
voluntarily because
long-standing social inequity uh
inequalities and health disparities have
resulted in covet 19
disproportionately affecting bypoc
individuals they will be granted an
exemption
if they cite their racial identity i
mean that's
that's definitely very bold that that's
definitely like some [ __ ] right
there
i think what they're doing is like
because systemic racism for example is
100 a real thing but that is probably
the dumbest
most idiotic way imaginable all of what
it is
but it's not though because you have
like you do have your maybe a good
policy
you have your what do you mean like name
if that's an example of like doing it
wrong
what's an example of rectifying systemic
racism correctly
sure so in these for example uh majority
black communities where they are
have much more rates of poverty and
higher rates of crime
obviously the reason for the high crime
rate is because of poverty
so i would uh like i'm not a policy
maker but i would like to see
more investment into those areas because
if we were for example able to
open up better businesses give people
more jobs
hire people that's what step one uh
that's gentrification
you're talking about sending in the
white upper class to black neighborhoods
to gentrify the neighborhood
to price them out you're a racist no no
no no i'm not arguing for that at all no
i'm not
that but then you know what i'm arguing
for is investing in that contract what
money where is it
where does the money come from it might
be this is called gentrification
when the situation is when the city when
white people move in and then rent
prices go up
that's that's a simplification
gentrification if they come in and they
start putting all this money into
buildings
and infrastructure and then the property
values that's skyrocketing these black
families are going to get priced out
taxed out and they're getting kicked out
that's not what i want to happen what i
want to see happen
is more business investments more
specific so let me ask you a question
if more businesses start popping up in
these neighborhoods right
will property value go up you tell me
well the answer is yes of course more
more business means more taxes means
more commerce more tax revenue better
streets better buildings
better repairs and tax tax goes up right
right what do you think happens to these
poor black families who now can't pay
the higher tax rates because their
property value went up well that's the
problem right there is see
i don't want these big companies to just
come in start opening up and then
raising the prices
what i want is to see a proper
investment into this area
where not only is it just people coming
along investment from who
to what listen listen listen you
understand what you're saying is
extremely racist
you're promoting the eviction of black
families pricing
no no no what you're doing is you're
trying to use this like liberal
hypocrisy thing on me i know
i know no no no what i'm telling you is
what you're advocating for by the left
is considered wrong
i don't care what the left thinks i'm
not a leftist but i'm not supposed
to work so i don't stand by my positions
that's what i do
when i when i'm telling you that you're
proposing a policy to end systemic
racism
you're not that's not my policy that's
what we
want you to use so listen another option
would be we need to stop funding schools
with the taxes collected in that
neighborhood obviously
because that creates a vicious cycle
where then you have poor people going to
[ __ ] schools and it
repeats forever that's another example
of what we can do to fix it
but again i'm not a policy maker and i
recognize that what i've said about
investing in those areas is a rather
uh surface level and simplified version
of what i think could help
for me i'm more interested in talking to
people about systemic racism right now
because we first have to acknowledge
that the problem even exists
before we can go about fixing the
problem and how would you define
systemic criticism
well i define systemic racism a little
differently than i think a lot of people
would
for me uh systemic racism would be
it's often times like you can see it in
history and then you can see it today
still so you can see where that racist
policy was created
how it affected blacks and how it's
still affecting them today in mind or
any other minority group or any other
minority group sure like
systemic racism majority majority
major league majorly majorly affects
like
black people for the most part but yeah
they're other people can be victims of
systemic racism too
does it does it predominantly affect
black families or black people
yeah and that's because and that's
because a lot of the reasons that
black people are in the position they
are today is of course because of
historical racist policies from america
like red lining is a perfect example
and blockbusting yeah yeah i mean
there's there's plenty of them even the
war on drugs right which
i mean joe biden further exacerbated
with the crime bill like
there's plenty of cia luke you know
about cia and crack right yes oh yeah
yeah there was also the um the the crack
versus cocaine thing
let me tell you uh the modern left right
now doesn't understand what systemic
racism is
and neither does the right they think
systemic means institutionalized
and so it's really hard to have a
conversation with people about systemic
racism
because they immediately think
institutionalized right so their
response immediately is like well then
tell me about an institution that's like
no no
i'm talking about systemic right and
they say well you mean historical i'm
like yes that's what systemic meant the
system
created a problem it's it's we're not
talking about the institution of
policing or hospitals or schools we're
talking about
the easiest example i give to people is
uh because i did a documentary on this
pruitt i go commute public housing in st
louis
the st louis county racial housing
covenants in the suburbs
most people don't realize that st louis
isn't isn't one city when people say st
louis they're referring to like 90
different cities
all of these little tiny cities that
surround it going westward
that were formed because people white
people were fleeing the inner city due
to increasing poverty and crime
and because of racism they created new
townships and then immediately enacted
racial covenants
so these are laws that are no longer
legal right but it basically created a
system that created a two-tier
like oversimplifying things for sure but
you basically create two tracks where
one is doing well and one is doing
poorly
you get rid of the laws that made this
problem happen like redlining or
blockbusting
and now we're dealing with the
generational after effects of why these
people
are in in poverty why there's crime in
there is the problem
is we're now at a point now where after
we've gotten rid of the racist racist
laws
we we had racist law we had racial
covenants
and now we have the modern left
advocating for bringing back
racial law and i'm like well that's the
stupidest thing you've ever heard
uh like talking about in policies
directed towards different races or
affirmative action like policies
you're just talking about creating more
laws like look at this way if you went
back in time and
and said we're gonna create a law for
white people to protect them then people
would argue but it's just a positive
thing it doesn't hurt them it's you know
well no it's creating a disproportionate
effect which will result in one you know
group of people doing better than the
other
which will lead to poverty crime and
other detriments because you're
essentially you know
you can make the argument but ultimately
you have a two-track system creates
systemic racism
today they're saying basically the same
thing and if you look at like ibram ex
candy his argument
is that we need more discrimination
that's what we need more discrimination
and that's like okay he would have fit
in really really well
with the people in the 50s who wanted
separate but equal right that's
basically what he's advocating for
more he says the solution to past
discrimination
is present discrimination or i can't
remember the exact quote but
it was something like that it passed
present discrimination what towards
white people no tour
towards everybody oh like he just wants
to continue being yeah so so his idea is
like you know
i'm trying to steal men's argument that
if you have people who are
disproportionately affected by
past you know historical precedent and
laws then we need to target different
communities based on race and
discriminate positively or negatively
meaning negative towards one group
that's doing too well like asians for
instance and positive towards the
latinos who aren't doing as well
yes yeah i would disagree with that
entirely i don't think that we should be
stifling one to try to bring them down i
think what we should try to be doing is
helping the communities that are where
they are today because of american
policies in the history
of the past get to where everyone else
is i don't i've never agreed with this
idea of
tearing one down to try to bring one up
kind of crap
i know that there's a lot of like lib
[ __ ] and people that advocate for crap
like that
um but no i would never be in favor of
it well there's different issues to
really kind of consider here because if
you're going
to if you're going to try to help people
who are hurt historically
you know what about the polish people
who are subjugated by the nazis and then
the ussr like
well there's there's also i mean we can
go about like
i think there are going to be different
ways that we can address different kind
of historical
like oppressions but the main reason
that i think it's so important that we
focus on
black people in america right now is
because this is a really prevalent
example of where a
huge group of people are still being
greatly disproportionately affected by
policies that although are no longer
like on the books
the results of that poli those policies
still exist right
so the problem now is having done away
with those laws
we've an end with the passing of things
like loving v virginia
we've now created not just one community
it's not just the black community
anymore it is the impo
the the you know poor neighborhoods and
i'm not saying you know not all black
neighbors are poor if you look at where
obama was you know in hyde park it's
it's very well off right so targeting it
based on race is a mistake
you don't like we don't wanna you don't
think the obama family needs help
certainly not they're some of the
smartest and most accomplished people
in the world well i do think i so
singling out race would be you know
well i mean obviously it's not to say
that all black people are living in
poverty and i wouldn't say that
to fix systemic racism we have so the
answer is
class-based resolutions well i would
argue that the reason
see the reason that black people are in
poverty is because
specifically because they are black
because they were discriminated against
because of that so that's a bold
statement
that was extremely dangerous black
people are black people were
historically discriminated against and
that's why they are today that's what we
were just agreeing on i feel like i've
had more than enough uh guests on this
show
who would completely disagree with you
and are literally black
see the problem i don't care what i mean
that's identity politics i'm not
concerned about what
the the the thing i i'm more you're not
concerned with
a what black peop you know what's right
for their community and you don't hear
what they know
no not at all i'm what i'm saying and
that they're all poor no
did i did i say that all black people
were poor did i say that black all black
people it was very generalized
did i did i say that all black people
report no you said that they're poor
the sole reason they're poor is because
they're black no
oh good one tim isn't that what you said
no i said they are they
are discriminated against for being
black so it is b it's based on race
because they were discriminated against
in the past
because of their race right obviously
they're not poor because they're black
they're poor because
that black people are disproportionately
poor because black people were
discriminated against in the past
because of their race
that's wrong you know why why because
what about immigrants who came here like
10 years ago
that's entirely different actually are
you talking about um nigerians
haitians i mean i i'm not too familiar
with haitians but i know nigerians for
example are cited a lot of the times as
an example of
uh like how can systemic racism exist
and a lot
i agree stomach racism exists i just
think that we shouldn't
use race as the factor because you've
got multi generations
of families that have now existed
outside of the confines of racial
covenants and racial laws
you have immigrants for generations who
have come in and faced completely
different circumstances
sure and if individuals are racist
there's no real
hard solution for that because you know
people still have some
level of freedom to associate now i'm
actually fairly liberal
on a lot of issues particularly like i
think if you're operating a business
in public you have to serve the public
within reason so like
i actually agree that you know we should
have laws saying you want to run a
bakery and someone comes in and says i
require service you give it to him
now the specific example with the baker
in colorado was that he wouldn't write a
message it's very different that that i
actually think he shouldn't have to do
but if i own a own a shop you should be
able to say this particular group is
barred from entry that's wrong
sure yeah so if if if we're dealing with
a way to solve systemic racism
which exists it's actually impossible to
solve by using racial law
or saying we're going to give money to a
community based on their race
because you'll get you'll end up giving
a haitian immigrant you know sure and
i'm not in the same circumstances no no
no no i think that this is a bit of a
misrepresentation and again i understand
that i i
i'm not a policymaker here so but uh
no i'm not saying we just go give money
to black communities i'm saying we would
invest
in yes in those poor communities that
oftentimes
unfortunately tend to be black as well
and the reason for that
is because of historical inequality so
i'm not saying that racial laws are the
solution but i'm saying that
acknowledging that black people are
where they are today largely because
they were discriminated against because
of their race
that's just the fact of the matter it
was they got a bunch of the slaves it
basically came from they're
discriminated against because they were
like the
descendants of slaves and didn't have
any money coming out there was no
historical wealth
why when we look at when we look at
american history we see a history of a
lot of immigrants of a lot of
discrimination
a lot of different groups are
discriminated against but i particularly
wanted to get your point on the new york
city school superintendent
saying when their school when their
school resources it shouldn't go to the
poor white kid it should go to the
middle class and even upper class black
kid
i mean that's dumb okay that's very dumb
obviously i mean yeah
we're talking about this is like this is
such a huge problem that the left does
all the time which is where we are
criticizing systems and then they apply
or then they apply that to an individual
which is really really a problem i mean
white privilege is like a perfect
example like
you can talk about on a statistical
level white people
might have some level of privilege over
other groups
but if you then go up to one single
white guy and be like screw-offs
privileged white boy
that's like a problem because it's
you're supposed to be
compassionate towards people and
ruthless towards systems right that's uh
kind of like
what i like to do thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you